ja
zwölf zu fünf
hätte ich meine pvp sache denn ich auch
ein bisschen was reißen kann
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer gewissen des server und wo man
steht nicht warum also einer die server
und schon hab ich mir gedacht ich habe
ja vor einer langen zeit mal gesagt dass
ich mir eventuell mal ein paar server
angucken werde das ist jetzt war nicht
ganz genau so dass aber ihr könnt
einfach irgendwelche server wo man
eventuell mini spiele spielen kann oder
wo man häuser bauen kann et cetera
einfach in die kommentare schreiben
eventuell mal so ein paar videos wo ich
dann auf die server drauf gehe und ist
im rumlaufen und ein bisschen rum gruppe
und einfach so ein bisschen chillen halt
und das ist das auch gerade uns war es
das einfach halo in minecraft ich habe
dazu ja schon meine mode review gemacht
dass es allerdings was anderes und zwar
ist das ja ein server wo man halo
spielen kann und ich hab da bisher erst
ein paar videos auf youtube gesehen und
hab mir dann gedacht könnte ich ja mal
einfach austesten ich habe mir das
tutorial ein bisschen angeguckt habe es
aber immer noch nie verstanden
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich gehe
hier einfach drauf und spiel das mit
euch ein bisschen und versuche mir das
hier mit euch so ein bisschen ich doch
mal
anzugucken also ich habs jetzt noch kein
mal gespielt deswegen bin ich jetzt noch
ein totaler kkp ich weiß weiß
wahrscheinlich nicht mal wo ich
irgendwie spielen kann oder sogar doch
jetzt das match das sind 32 leute das
ist voll das auch voll das ist nicht
voll
und wir spielen das jetzt einfach mal
zusammen also ist es wirklich das
allererste mal deswegen werden die
kommentare schreibt nun oder irgendwie
sowas das vollkommen legitim ich spiele
gerade selber zum ersten mal also mit
rechtsklick mit recht kann ich schießen
ja genommen rechts schießen ihr seht
wahrscheinlich rechts unten dieses grüne
ist dass ich immer nach laden muss also
ich kann sich die ganze zeit
hintereinander schießen sondern muss
erst wieder grünes bin im team blau das
seht ihr hier weil ich diese blaue
wollen handhabt das ist meine munition
die geht
laut das ist wahr das ist dieses quasi
wenn ich nach laden will also erklärt
sich von selbst das ist meine waffe
diesmal ganz links und das ist ein
ernstes wort das ist so halt einfach vom
nahkampf also wenn ich dann irgendwo
hingehen
kann ich denn hier ist einfach schlagen
und der ist jetzt tot und jetzt habe ich
ein kind hey cool ich hab noch hitzacker
das ist richtig gut für mich naja gut
also ich find das macht spaß wenn
eventuell mehr von halo wollten erfahren
daumen hoch geben und in die kommentare
schreiben und dann geht eventuell mehr
von halo kommen weil ich finde mir macht
echt spaß wir sind jetzt zwar nicht
relativ viele leute ich auf dem server
allerdings ist es ist rechts wie bei die
haie ich sehe meine scores also 100 weil
ich ein keller pro keller 100 punkte da
ist die blaue allerdings gibt es kein
team rot irgendwie also seht schon da
hinten war unsere pace das ist hier die
base von team rotiert server ip et
cetera in der beschreibung
wieso ist denn jetzt kann das ja
langweilig dann ach so sie nur 30
sekunden zurück ja okay dann ist gut
wir führen auch 410 00 also muss man
immer gucken ich glaube man kriegt auch
in die zehn punkte führen es ist oder
irgendwie sowas ich weiß nicht ich bin
es ja gerade zum ersten mal versucht
euch das dah ein bisschen näher zu
bringen das heißt ich lerne das gerade
mit euch kennen ich finde es eigentlich
ganz cool dass ich dann sage ich mal
hier unwissend bin und damit euch
einfach so ein bisschen rum chile und
blauen block bund alles und ja hier ist
reload wird nur kann ich doch jetzt
schießt
ach so ist vorbei ich will nachladen und
dann wie vor bei egal jetzt startet hat
eine neue runde neue map neue map map
ist nur neue map jetzt ist eine neue map
cool die web gibt es wirklich bei halo
alter die konzerte sind echte im halo
karten das ist ja geil bei halo war da
hinten immer so ein fahrzeuge herum
fahren konnte wo man das ist eine gute
alte zeiten das hab ich damals einen
freund gespielt
das war vor vier fünf sechs jahren oder
sollte das gespielt dann brach schön die
erinnerung da werde ich ganz
melancholisch so haben wir überhaupt
welche im team rot in diesem jahr keiner
im team rot
sehr traurig dass er keiner ist
das ist ein langweiliges spiel hier
gerade hört sich also ich sag mal wenn
es dann in der 1.6 common werde dazu ich
möchte auch keine snatchers mehr
vorstellen sondern nur diese größeren
version dass auch die wahrscheinlich
schon mitbekommen
und zwar wenn es dann pferde gibt dann
frage ich nicht alter wenn die dann noch
texturen haben weil ihr wenig auf den
server geht müsst ihr einfach ich zeige
euch das mal ganz kurz optionen
grafikeinstellungen server texturen an
das macht er einfach an und dann geht
ihr auf diesen server dann wird da
gesagt ja willst du das jetzt
automatisch untereinander klickt einfach
auf ja dann habt ihr auch hier dieses
texture pack weil wir nicht dass die
volltext spende drin hätte
es würde ja das ist jetzt nur auf dem
server also wenn ich das drin hätte dann
wäre die sniper rifle zum beispiel
einfach nur irgendwie die diese also
diese munition ist ganz normale goldner
jetzt und so also dass ich ja nicht ganz
so schön deswegen ist das hiermit schon
geil so ich frage mich nur unsere gegner
sind irgendwie weg deswegen werde ich
jetzt erstmal wie kann man das machen ja
cool kann man machen
deswegen werde rausgehen dass er dann
relativ witzlos wenn er keine gegner
sind ich habe auch schon welche erkannt
also sind welche form herumlaufen sieht
man dass noch ein chat irgendwo
sieht man das sieht man das nicht man
das neue kann man irgendwie irgendwie
weiter oben naja gut wo kann man jetzt
nicht hier ein genial in 29 von 30 ist
doch perfekt perfekt so jetzt kommt die
erste richtige runde wo wir durch die
burschen werden
ich werde ich mir erstmal stoppen
los komm her 80 menschen tot so schnell
wieder auf die waffe auf die sniper
rifle also wirklich also mir macht
dieses halo echte menge spaß ich liebe
ja minecraft mittlerweile spiele ich
auch schon mit am meisten weil einfach
braucht man wieder kein punkt weil es
diese komplette abwechslung mittlerweile
gibt sich diese ganzen minispiele taten
etc
komm her wo bist du bist du da
warum kriegt sich gar kein mensch ist
das blöd
endlich ich habe ein kinn
ein verdammt ich bin sturm acht tage
komm her an dem verfolgt der schon
ich will neue waffe kann ich mir eine
neue waffe holen oder so also muss ich
mir wirklich noch alles angucken
wo ich habe zweiten kind wie das
komplette spiel prinzip funktioniert wie
man sich neue waffen holt etc dann werde
ich da wahrscheinlich auch schon viel
besser sein fachmännisch wieder tot also
neue waffen irgendwie für nahkampf oder
so eine shotgun das wäre schon geil
minecraft gott bitte bisher -
da kann ich aussprechen kann ich nicht
schade ich dachte dass wir mal einen
schuss richtung gerade also wirklich
immer auf entfernung mit der sniper
rifle würde ich jetzt erstmal sagen
no ma holt du-ri lauter
der fk oder hakt bei mir ich glaub es
hackt einfach bei mir und ich bin ihr im
moment leicht rote ja ich bin tot ich
sags ja nicht an ich dachte ich hätte
ein getötet aber der fall ist gestorben
das hat man wie wir das jetzt mit dem
reader und nachher ich muss halten damit
nicht überhören kann stimmt ihn
biologischen so weit so kann ja auch
angesehen wenn ich mich so rücke das ist
auch cool also wenn jetzt wirklich ihnen
und ja ich bin gestorben ich weiß nicht
wie aber okay also wenn jetzt wirklich
jemand in die kommentare schreibt hey du
bist ja so nur blabla
also ich weiss ich spiele das auch
gerade zum ersten mal
dahin
spiel das gerade zum ersten mal von
daher kann ich euch jetzt auch nicht so
die pro gameplays liefern kann ich
wahrscheinlich sonst auch nicht
wann ich will danke danke schön finde
ich im moment so
geht's auch erst mal sterben hier schön
schön
also ich kann euch jetzt nicht so die
pro gameplays liefern das ist einfach so
die sache ich werde das jetzt noch ein
bisschen spielen ich hab ja halo selber
auch für pc allerdings
spielt das nicht so häufig da ich
wirklich mittlerweile echt eine menge
eine menge wer wenig zeit hat wegen
abiturvorbereitungen ipad oder block
vorbei also ich mache noch kein abitur
aber halt schon so während und so also
für klausuren du nimmst du scheiße ich
doch vieles was man
daher meistens wenn ich ihnen was da
noch auf berichtet wieder campieren
weiter wird darüber hat er da da da da
da da da da da ich will ich mir
schnappen
nochmal meine schläge an ihr blödmann
ich weiß manchmal wenn wir da jetzt
allerdings hielt kloten
ja
sagt ihnen wie alles so ein bisschen
also mittlerweile rentner ja auch
einfach immer bei wäre nicht zocken weil
das geht einfach ist mittlerweile mit
meinem pc aber es ist schon krass
also ich habe bock dass hier weiter zu
spielen also dass meine kommentare ob er
dafür sei dass ich einerseits mehr halo
macher und andererseits
noch dings also mehr so einfach so auf
server gehen weil ihnen das spielen so
einfach überhaupt kein plan so bisschen
schön genauso diese blogs also darauf
habe ich in mittlerweile mehr noch als
sein steifes gameplay irgendwie von
informationen ansprechen sondern einfach
so wo ich so viele bis zum aufnehmen
und ja ich wäre jetzt mal versuchen ein
bisschen von hinten anzugreifen
ich muss ich noch informieren wie man
sich eventuell bessere waffen kaufen
kann und so weiter also da gab es ja
eine tutorial und wichtiger game hab ich
mir das natürlich nicht durchgelesen
sind
skills gehofft und hier komme ich auch
gar nicht weiter sehen
dann bin ich in die haare perfekt kann
gehe ich doch einfach ein bisschen hin
ich kann auch mal einfach hier ganz
tricks und eine maus empfindlichkeit
runterstellen ja das ist doch geil
ja danke
hay habe ich ein kind
so macht es spaß
und man diese dann hinten die ganze zeit
diese komischen hat mich gesehen scheiße
der penner mich gesehen
ach jetzt hab ich grad runter berlin
töten
egal da natürlich nicht hier wieder hin
du bist dran nein hab mir geklaut
daneben sie da hinten los los trifft
noch
neun habe ich auch meine hat mich
entdeckt jetzt habe ich wieder nur
sonntag ein paar katheder
also 33 also wer es nicht nur laut kdg
10 akademie gibt es fast gar nicht mehr
doch gibt es aber ich habe schon kills
ja so schnell in deckung in deckung
ich versuche es mal so hier ein bisschen
naja ok
man kann sich auch nicht bewegen muss
irgendwie nein das war schon wieder
nicht mein geld ich diese ganzen
blödmänner hier also erstmal nach laden
man kann sich auch nicht bewegen wenn
man es nicht
so kommt von hinten dran hier so da
zwei
akademie b in ruhe nein wenn nämlich
einmal steckt nicht tot
egal kommen jetzt hier
anders wieder nicht denke
ich stehe ich vor dem und kann ihn nicht
abgefallen ob man etwas traurig all das
war echt bitter
orange wieder in kiel 7 zu viel das ist
ein richtiges massaker runde hier also
in titel wird wahrscheinlich massaker
runde stehen die erste runde war keine
massaker aber die hier das ist das macht
spaß also macht diese szene echt
verdammt viel spaß dafür dass jetzt
gerade zum ersten mal spiele ich finde
ich echt ganz cool 9
das war das war bernard
bundes werde sich jetzt auch noch direkt
afag das regt mich echt auf mit diesen
karten nach land das ist immer vergessen
so
müsst ihr wart ich werde jetzt eine
taktik aus denkt und zwar werde auch
ich werde mich jetzt hier hinstellen so
relativ nah dran an rand ja genauso hier
ca doch ein bisschen schutz
taktik bringen ja
noch ok
12.25
hätte ich meine pvp sachen der ich auch
ein bisschen was reißen kann naja ok die
anderen hier ganzen anderen mensch war
ich jetzt besser spieler genau was die
ampel wird 2100 270 genau ich hatte
glaube ich 1300 oder so mit meinen zwölf
kirchen parks ist uns allen klar kommt
ich meine ich noch eine runde
ja klar also freunde spielt das auch
wenn ihr bei mir auf der serverseite
ankaufen irgendwelche sachen ich weiß es
nicht mir macht total spaß hier ist ein
typ der weil der hat geschossen genau du
da
ja
wer eine 3d ich habe eine drei ak.de
gaal immer noch
nicht
nach land
und wo sind die leute da
warum sterben nicht ich treffe jedoch
die ganze zeit auf uk the people
übrigens heute keine face camp weil ich
total fertig aus elf an gestern wir ein
bisschen laufen und so unklar und haben
noch nicht geduscht und ja also ich
denke hier ist so aber vielleicht könnte
auch mal die kommentare schreiben ich
zwinge mich richtig alles um kommentare
zu schreiben
wenn ihr wollt dass sich videos machen
wo ich auch total scheiße aus der dann
können die es mir einfach schreiben
da kann ich ja nicht rein ende des
feldes bauern von denen das ist eher
traurig
sowas eben hier nach laden ich glaube
ich werde meine einstellung müssen
umstellen damit das ganze hier noch
flüssiger läuft ich mein ich habe ja als
ich nehme auch deswegen hab ich grad 60
fps allerdings werde ich das mal eben so
machen ach ich hab das ja schon alles
auch schnell und so jahren und passt und
ich werde mein sichtfeld mal so ein
bisschen hier so auf 80 machen das ist
noch ein bisschen kleiner
wenn sie das ganze armeen ea louse sie
können natürlich auch ein schöner machen
aber ich glaube dir funktioniert ich mit
diesem texture pack gilt sowohl auf
herum laufen laufen laufen laufen
ach das ist auch wieder
so kurz noch nach laden eine firma kd
managers hat so spaß wenn man das spiel
ein bisschen verstanden hat das ist echt
hammer geil kann ich echt jedem nur
weiterempfehlen ist für mich besser pvp
medium pvp-modus zurzeit wie schon
gesagt ip stand irgendwie description
weidinger geld
ja kommt durch hierhin los los los geht
voll auf die schnauze ja oder ich halt
auch mal passieren ich profi nein ich
bin wahrscheinlich total schlecht im
vergleich zu den ganzen anderen
klar wenn man sich auch noch irgendwie
so ging's angucken könnte also darum ist
ums bauen das ist ja auch einfach wenn
man eine gute karte hat kann sich auch
einfach einstellen theoretisch so wie
man das bei call of duty auch machen
könnte kann die da gibt's ja kein spawn
ein der für den verband und endet nach
man ich kann einfach keine knicke
jacke
schnell aus und wenn wir jetzt schnell
julia okay jetzt ab in nahkampf freunde
jetzt wird jetzt geht's ab jetzt kommt
nahkampf action nahkampf action von von
crafter ^ ^ 17 wir spüren jetzt einfach
mal hier in das lager von denen rein
irgendwie sind wir auch wieder stark
überlegen hier ich glaube ich dass dort
erst mal jahre ich mich wieder
umgewöhnen kann hier wenn ich dass uns
die ganze zeit zocker auf das normale
minecraft mit dem springen und so einen
scheiß
so jetzt erst mal wieder schön nach
laden hier jetzt stellen wir uns hier
schön hin und können unsere kollegen da
oben jetzt nicht abschließend ich weiß
nicht warum das nicht ging
da kommt einer nahkampf ja ja kaum
rücktritt tiger congo im weltall
startete engagiert ist rot wieder ein
name
ach jetzt wären wir hier schon langsam
überheblich so kommen runterkommen
runterkommen runterkommen runterkommen
runter oder bleibt einfach stehen macht
ja auch nicht ich dich halt hier
ich möchte schon starken einander nein
ich hasse das wenn die auch im nahkampf
gehen das ist dann nicht so schön muss
mir ganz kürzlich ein bisschen heilen so
so so so so
schnell weg schnell weg schnell weg nach
land und ab wieder auf das energy smart
ab in nahkampf so war seitdem wusste wo
seid ihr da ist wieder jemand hier
stirbt mal wieder hieß
das wieder red devils wieder rot werden
tierretter ok oder auch nicht dann halt
nicht ja ja
so wie lange geht es noch wie lange es
noch es geht noch 30 sekunden müssen wir
schnell hier noch ein hehl machen nein
es geht los
8 vorbei mensch ja gut freunde dann
würde ich erst mal sagen wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten mal freude schindet
mit mir hier drauf also dann mache ich
das jetzt hier sagen also nein
da
passt green shots gemacht hier für euch
ja dann würde ich einfach sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat einfach ein daumen
hoch gehen wenn ihr wollt auch einfach
einen daumen hoch geben und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder ich
mache jetzt noch ganz schnell ein kind
ja ich bin süchtig wie sonst was
wahrscheinlich werde ich einfach jeder
runde jetzt auf nämlich die spieler also
wenn ihr mehr halo wollt
könnt ihr ist einfach in die kommentare
schreiben acht minister da kennt er ja
kommen
aber auch hier
wenn man nicht andere waffen kriegen
könnte dann wäre echt cool
und ab zum ende und wir sehen
uns dann einfach beim nächsten mal
tschüss